not since the fall of 2019 has the
corporate chess league been held live
tonight it's a hybrid event
players from edward jones enterprise
ascension and dougherty will be
competing right here in the tournament
hall while players from bear wwt edward
jones and enterprise will be competing
from the comfort of their own homes via
chess.com all the points for both
platforms will be added up to see which
team can be the first and hopefully last
hybrid event winner which corporation
was successfully mixing up tonight
find out
now
hello everyone and welcome back to the
corporate chess league as always my name
is caleb denby and tonight as you've
seen from mike already it's a very
special night for the corporate chess
league for the first time in about two
years we are returning with in-person
chess for our corporate chess league
players that's right they're up there in
the tournament hall right now getting
ready for round one which is set to get
underway in just a few minutes here
and i'm really excited to have all these
guys back in st louis saw some people i
haven't seen in a long long time and
it's great to have chess players back at
the chess club
um so what are we doing here well let's
take a look at our teams for tonight
of course we have six teams in the
corporate chess league
i'm talking about enterprise docherty
edward jones ascension worldwide
technology and bayer all competing for
the top four spots in this grand prix
season and then the final four are going
to square off again in just a few weeks
here coming up in november so these
players are running out of time to score
grand prix points to make it into those
finals
uh now i think we just have those six
teams for this season of the corporate
chess league but if you yourself are a
member of a corporation in the st louis
area you too can get involved please we
would love to hear from you reach out to
us at development st louis chessclub.org
and we'll get back to you with tons of
information on how you can join and
start your very own corporate chess
league team
aside from that where do we stand in
these uh grand chess tour standings
right now well it looks like
uh grand prix standings we have
enterprise on top with 155 and a half
points we have worldwide technology in
second place with 140 points edward
jones has
113.5 and ascension has 83.5 so those
four teams in very good position to
qualify for the final four
now darty and bayer got off to a slow
start this season but dardy has an
advantage that uh worldwide technology
does not and that is that they are
playing in this in-person event so they
have more opportunities to score points
that being said it's going to take a
miracle for darny and bear to get back
into the final four but uh miracles
happen miracles happen all the time
now with that out of the way let's see
where we stand for our pairings for
round one
so of course we have enterprise squaring
off against doherty and we have edward
jones up against ascension and those are
the only games we'll be looking at
tonight because those are our in-person
competitors they made the journey out to
the chess club they are up in the
tournament hall right now getting ready
to play and we will be following those
games very closely
uh now
interestingly enterprise and edward
jones are also competing in the online
portion of this hybrid event which means
they again are going to have some more
opportunities to score points
now these in-person teams they're
competing for 72 points total if every
member of your team wins every game then
you get 72 points but
nobody's going to get that many points
you get 20 points for winning the team
match and then you get one extra point
for each win you get in in the
individual games and that's how you add
up to that magic number of 72.
well with all that information i think
we are set to get underway in just a
moment here uh we'll let all those
players get settled in up in the
tournament hall and in the meantime
hello hello to everyone in the chat room
thank you so much for joining me here
tonight it's gonna be a uh gonna be an
exciting uh and exciting night of chess
going to be very exciting uh we are
playing rapid chess here at the chess
club i believe the same time control as
the online event so expect to see some
flags you know online chess is one thing
trying to move quickly but over the
board it goes even faster it takes so
much time to physically move those
pieces hit the clock and continue on our
way
um
and it looks like the the players are
sitting down and are about to uh to get
started here so i'm awaiting uh the
moves on my pgn here we'll let it uh
take a second to get updated
uh but yeah hello hello hello to orange
in the chat mr obvious
zen master
uh parapsychic musings and jamie diamond
parapsychic says miracles can't happen
all the time by definition it's a big
world parasitic miracles happen all the
time they just happen rarely in each in
each spot i don't know if that made any
sense but i'm sticking with it anyways
let me take you through
our lineup here so on board one we've
got john boyer who is i believe captain
of the enterprise team and he's leading
the charge for his team he's rated 1900
he's one of the highest rated players in
the event and he's up against eli asradi
who is board one for dardy
and i believe does not have an official
over-the-board rating so one of these
online chess players that came about
during the pandemic i'm sure with the
chess boom going on so john boyer
definitely a huge favorite for
enterprise on board one but then
something interesting happens on the
enterprise team we take a look at board
two we've got thomas stack i believe has
only played one or two over the board
tournaments in his life and is rated
about 1100 so that's an 800 point gap
between board one and board two for
enterprise so it's gonna be really
interesting to see how that interesting
um
team dynamic is going to play out john
boyer is going to have to score a lot of
points uh to keep up with board two
meanwhile uh thomas stack is up against
chris sell who i believe is also
predominantly an online chess player
moving on down the line we've got ken ma
now with the black pieces for enterprise
up against nathan watson playing for
darty and we've got michael prather
again with black now for enterprise up
against jon fingers with the white
pieces that brings us to our second
match of the day which is going to be
between vishwa
vishal bardwash up against nick ragon
uh vishal is the highest rated player in
the event coming in with a strong 1940
rating
up against nick ragon who appears to be
around 1600
board 2 for edward jones is justin
beckstead
with a rating of 1591 believe that is
the strongest board 2 in the event so
edward jones looking a little stacked
strongest board one strongest board two
and he's playing steve gilmore who is
also rated around 1500 and of course
he's playing for the ascension team
continuing on steven evans with the
black pieces for edward jones also at
1576 pretty high rated up against thomas
schaffer
maybe maybe that's how you pronounce
that we'll never know and lastly alex
kerfur don't think we would forget about
alex the edward jones captain is
actually playing board four which is
rather interesting we've seen alex you
know on board one or two in the online
events because i believe he is a little
bit underrated over the board his over
the board rating only 1550 is online
rating around 1900 so
interesting to see him in this board for
slot definitely not where he's used to
being but maybe he can score even more
points for edward jones with that in
mind and of course he is playing maurice
perry
uh and that's all the players so again
we are just waiting on the pgns to get
going here
and in the meantime we'll uh
we'll just hang out a little bit
hello hello to brian ketterin
how are you doing
and oh my god they all appeared all at
once okay so games are underway let's
take a look at what's going on here with
john boyer versus eli ezrati it looks
like we have a london from john
uh a more conservative start oh but then
he tricked his opponent
uh eli asrati maybe knows a thing or two
about the london goes for this king's
indian defense setup and this is sort of
known as the way to uh to punish london
players you know by not taking the
center early uh eli israeli is hoping to
activate this bishop on the long
diagonal and if john boyer had stuck to
his guns played something like c3 really
tried to get the london set up black's
going to get a good position i think
that's why we saw john break out break
out now with c4 uh so kind of switching
it up now that he sees that eli is
committed to this king's indian defense
setup that being said black has a
perfectly fine position and in fact he
goes knight h5 trying to pick up this
dark squared bishop see john go bishop
g5 trying to save it but
black tries to track it down with
h6
after bishop h4 though we see that black
is not fully committed to the idea as he
does not continue out now with g5 i
think g5 in this case would be very very
risky on account of the fact that you're
leaving this knight hanging
i'm not sure if there's any immediate
tactics
for example if you take on g5
and take here you actually lose the
bishop as well but definitely it's a
scary move to play maybe that's why eli
went for f6 instead going for e5 but it
feels a little bit wrong to push all of
these pawns so far out
and in fact john immediately capitalizes
on this by winning a pawn on h5 we get
bishop h7 f4 queen e8 queen f3 and now
after c5 d5 and jon is just up a clean
pawn here so
black is you know not totally dead not
totally out of it but white's pieces all
make sense black isn't getting some kind
of crazy attack here and so i would much
rather be john in in this position i
would definitely rather be john so as
expected john boyer looking good on
board one thus far let's take a look now
at board 2 where we've got thomas stack
with the white pieces rated just a
thousand but maybe he's a little bit
underrated maybe he's also been playing
a lot of chess during the pandemic
and let's just check out this opening it
starts with d4
and wow we're getting something very
similar another king's indian defense
and thomas is going for
this f3 setup uh
okay
queen d2 d5
castle's queen side there it is and we
get this takes on d5 take on d5 setup so
against these f3 structures chris cell
has accurately decided to go for the c5
plan rather than the quote-unquote more
normal e5 plan in the king's indian and
i think that this is a great way to
handle it because now
after c5 and d5 we see this bishop is
wide open on this diagonal instead of
sort of blocked in like you would see
with the with the pawn on e5 and since
this bishop is so open it's going to be
pressuring this queen side just a little
bit where the white king resides and
black is again just going to try and
attack on this side of the board in the
meantime though it is a benoni structure
so white's going to have a nice edge in
the center a little bit of extra central
space and it's going to try to use that
to leverage it into a kingside attack
we see a6 so this is chris going for b5
b4 again trying to slice open that
diagonal meanwhile thomas stack not
going to waste any time goes h4 and g4
and h5
so it's it's one of those uh fun
opposite sides castling's positions
where both players are just racing to
checkmate each other you love to see it
okay knight a4 bishop d7 b3
and knight takes g4 what's going on here
this is just a sacrifice of a piece uh
black picks up three pawns but i'm not
sure i'm in love with it because the
three pawns that you picked up were
pawns that were inhibiting uh the major
pieces from from attacking your king's
side so
really interesting decision here to go
knight takes on g4 by
by black i suppose he was worried about
g5 at some moment but you should be able
to get away with knight h5 this is a
pretty common idea
um for example like let's say he he
played a more normal move
i don't know okay let's just say you
passed
then even if white goes h6 and g5 you're
not so unhappy to play knight h5 this is
kind of an annoying piece for white to
deal with it's blocking this h file and
uh sort of locking out this rook from
from the position
now if i were black here i would
definitely be thinking about taking this
piece off the board
becoming knight b6 and just pushing him
just just pushing him
so i don't know if i'm in love with this
piece sacrifice but we're going to see
how it pays off for uh for chris here
uh you know in his defense he has
shattered the white center and this
knight's a little bit of stray although
i imagine it's gonna look to come back
in
but uh black's remaining pieces are
pretty decent this bishop's a monster on
the long diagonal this rook is very
active and this knight is going to be
able to jump in to some nice squares as
well the question is is the king safety
going to be too much of a problem
i'm inclined to say yes something like
bishop h6 and then just
attacking down these open lines looks
quite dangerous
um i think we might be having some
trouble with the dgt on ken ma versus
nathan watson so we'll skip over that
one for now and lastly
board 4 i also hope that we're having
trouble here either that or michael
prather got distracted by the open bar
and has not made a second move in his
game but um i expect that's not the case
so
for now looking good for uh enterprise
on these top two boards and we'll leave
it at that
okay with that let's check in on the
other match up we've got going on here
we've got uh vishal playing with the
white pieces up against nick rogon so
vishal of course the enter or the edward
jones board one the strongest player in
the event tonight up against nick who is
the board one for ascension we get d4 d5
and a pretty calm setup we see vishal
going for the catalan structures
but then he plays this really
interesting move rook to e1 i can't say
i'm exactly familiar with
white's idea here of course the normal
catalan
would happen after something like c4 you
know white tries to rip open this
diagonal using the c4 pawn as a lever
and again like in the benoni structures
he's just going for a monster bishop on
the long diagonal
with rookie one vessel seems to be going
for something entirely different he's
playing for an early e4 break rather
than the c4 break
so after castles knight b to d2 knight b
to d7 he does just play e4 straight away
really interesting idea
black ops 2 to capture this pawn and
that's always going to be a little bit
of a risk here for black
normally you want to keep this diagonal
as shut down as closed as possible and
taking on e4 that's definitely going to
open the diagonal up so we'll see what
he has in mind we get knight takes on e4
knight d5 c3 and c5
okay so what black is doing here is he's
saying
i don't care about your bishop on g2 all
of my pieces are going to be active all
of my pieces have squares that they want
to step to and if i'm active as well it
doesn't really matter that your bishop
has the open diagonal so black
very combative in this game going after
the center we get d take c5 by vishal
knight takes takes takes
and after some trades queen a4 sneaky
threat sneaky threat
bishop f5 and now
knight h4 queen b6 okay very dangerous
stuff here the f2 pawn is attacked the
bishop is also a little bit loose we see
rook to e2 in this case
and then yeah bishop to d3 so white was
making a serious threat here and that
threat is that this knight is going to
be left unguarded if you don't do
anything so after white deals with this
threat on f2 we see bishop to d3
stepping out of that idea also harassing
this rook a little bit that's why we get
rook d2 and now bishop b5 and i have to
say
you know impressive stuff by nick so far
like vishal highest rated player in the
event but just look at this activity
look at these raking bishops and what
does white have for it i'm not so sure
okay queen b3 knight f6
and we see a4 bishop back to a6 now
and yeah now b4 and it does feel like
something is starting to slip here for
black bishop c4 is is going to lose a
pawn now of course white was threatening
b5 just trapping this bishop
yeah i think here you definitely want to
put this bishop back on the c6 square
you have to have to have to
counteract this bishop on g2 it's just
too strong
um and
it's so strong that it won a pawn all by
itself okay bishop back to f3
and
white still has some some trouble here
right this bishop isn't ideal this
knight's a very strong piece threatening
the c3 pawn and black's rooks are going
to be getting rather active here but we
see vishal's working to solve those
problems and then a big decision by the
shalt he just snaps on d5 gets rid of
that strong bishop
in exchange for alleviating the pressure
on c3 just a little bit okay interesting
choice to capture back with the pawn by
nick now he's hoping to just clamp down
on the c4 square i think but yeah vishal
notices that this d5 pawn might be more
of a weakness than an asset
and by the way we have a result
as expected john boyer did end up
winning this very strong position that
he had with the extra pawn
let's see how he did it he went d5 f5
and then yeah won a second pawn in the
center
and then eli lost a piece on f5 not
ideal not ideal so far
yeah and we don't need to see the rest
of that game john is good enough to get
that one done okay let's continue on
down the board though we've got justin
beck's dead for edward jones up against
steve gilmore
justin the highest rated board two if
i'm not mistaken edward jones is
fielding the highest rated player on
every board that is that is in the
tournament they have the highest rated
board one board two board three and
board four so they're going to be
favored in all of their matchups uh
reminds me of the st louis archbishops
okay what is going on in this position
though yeah king g7 bishop takes h6 okay
that's an extra piece for white and
looking at the position it looks like
white was already up a piece uh but
before this happened so
i have to say looking very good for
justin beckstead and looking good for
edward jones on
the top two boards although
michelle's game was was a little bit uh
scary there for a second nick putting up
some very strong resistance
all right let's continue on down the
line here we have stephen evans playing
for edward jones up against thomas
schaffouch
something like that i don't know i'm
gonna i'm just gonna call him thomas
from now on that sounds good
but again it's looking quite nice for
edward jones we see that this bishop is
pinned along the d file
bishop can't move otherwise rook takes
rook and you are just losing your rook
for free
so it looks like steven is is about to
win a second piece here okay f4 uh and
wow stephen actually chooses to just
take on on c3 personally i might have
just played something like bishop f6
made my opponent uh just lose the full
piece you can't even defend it with rook
a2 because my other bishop guards that
square but i mean this is winning as
well obviously so bishop takes c3 and
that looks like three nice games for
edward jones lastly as expected alex is
cleaning up on board for two extra rooks
in this position for alex
and it's looking like a 4-0 start for
edward jones if i didn't know any better
i think edward jones might win four to
nothing
the only question mark left is this game
between vishal and nick but next down to
25 seconds
and we are not playing with increment uh
as far as i know actually no it might be
ten plus two i think it is ten plus two
um
so two second increment that's basically
just enough time to make a move if
you're really really fast
so essentially
zero seconds on the clock uh
zero second increment
and
here it looks like nick
is is yeah just just going to end up
losing this we're going to see king f5
vishal is going to pick up another pawn
and that's that's going to be the match
yeah bishop takes on g5 is trading into
a lost king and pawn end game
and
uh yeah vishal won't mess that one up so
it's looking like four nothing for
edward jones unless there's any
surprises
uh
and that's it yeah the shawl officially
wins up against nick here and wow
checkmate queens with checkmate pretty
strong
um checking back in let's take a look
over here at thomas against chris this
is the game where chris sacrificed a
piece early on um in order to get
some compensation and win a ton of pawns
it looks like disaster has happened for
thomas bishop h6 but that loses the
knight on e2 black gets the piece back
and
oh my god is this threefold repetition
there's no way this is threefold
repetition okay this position appears
once
this position appears once
twice twice
i think white can claim a draw with
queen f4
yeah if white knows about the rules of
repetition he can write down queen f4 or
just call the arbiter over declare his
intention to play queen f4 and declare a
draw by by repetition
so will he be able to do it yes he's
wrong oh and it's officially a draw so
disaster for chris cell uh he he had
everything he won three pawns and then
got his piece back and then here all he
needed to do is not repeat that extra
time here you can just take this bishop
you can develop your knight you can do
anything you want and you're just up
three clean pawns it is a little bit
scary with uh the the weak king but
honestly bishop h6 rook h6 queen g5 like
you might even be winning more stuff
unless white wants to play queen d2
trade the queens and lose the end game
um
but yeah if you go something like king
b1 i i think i can just take this this
this move isn't checkmate okay i might
have light this move might be checkmate
that move would be checkmate so
okay definitely some risk in the
position
but uh uh
not enough in my opinion to justify
taking a draw here at worst case you go
knight d7 you go knight f8 you defend
your king and you're gonna win this game
no matter what so
very surprising draw and kudos to thomas
stack recognizing the threefold
repetition it's really not easy to keep
your cool in the middle of the game here
and accurately count
the number of times you've repeated so
impressive stuff by thomas
and more results are trickling in here
we have stephen evans officially winning
against thomas schaffbook
with f6 pawn checkmate impressive stuff
and that just leaves alex against
maurice perry and i believe this game is
actually probably over might have
another relay error here um it's showing
that maurice lost on time but i imagine
we might have seen uh resignation in in
this position two extra rooks is pretty
good stuff pretty good stuff
uh so if i'm not mistaken that's a clean
4-0 sweep for edward jones a feat that
cannot be matched by enterprise after
this surprise repetition in the game
between thomas stack and chris cell and
i'm waiting on news
the rook defends e8 so queen e8 isn't a
move ah yes so that line i was
discussing there where
if i can get to it
where i played queen eight check
um of course the the rook just defends
this so you can do this i was right my
first instinct was right
best you have is check and check
and okay maybe you actually still don't
want to do this because of like ricotta
fate stuff so not the line that i showed
but
this definitely would be scary i would
just recommend taking that bishop off
the board bringing this knight to f8 and
then it's really hard for white to make
any progress you're just gonna go rook
uh rookie eight rookie one trade off the
major pieces and and end the game
yeah thanks to the youtube chat for the
correction on that one
and then yeah i'm waiting on news for
these other two games i think we had
some relay mistakes going on here pretty
sure this game didn't end on move two
and this game didn't end on move zero
but i could be wrong maybe we have a
have some some strange things going on
the move zero game never began one of
the players
oh my god and it's official we have a no
show that is why ken ma vs nathan watson
did not start
we are missing a player
so i wonder who it is is it nathan is it
ken is it both
and yeah still don't know what happened
with uh with michael prather against
john fingers here
uh we can only hope that it wasn't
another no show we can only hope
it appears that all the games have
concluded
and okay with that it's official that's
all games in round one are done uh
edward jones does win 4-0
uh and enterprise in the two games that
we saw won one and a half out of two
that being said they might have given up
a forfeit loss on board three uh unclear
which player actually forfeited and
board four also shrouded in mystery
shrouded in mystery
with that in mind though let me see if i
can pull up our pairings for round two
and see what we've got going on
okay round two it's going to be
ascension up against enterprise
essentially we just saw lose 4-zip to
edward jones so they'll they will
definitely be looking to stage a
comeback here uh and we have edward
jones up against darty
so
uh again it is a three round tournament
here tonight a round robin each team
plays each other once
and so uh
you know we're gonna see everybody play
everybody basically
but for next round let's flip on over to
it
and that is going to pit nick rigoni up
against john boyer steve gilmore up
against thomas stack thomas who although
having a bad position in round one
showed his uh practical resourcefulness
by claiming a three-fold repetition when
you know i expect his opponent didn't
entirely intend to repeat that many
times so thomas very aware of the legal
rules of chess which is always always a
plus
then hopefully we have ken ma against
thomas we have uh maurice perry up
against michael prather on board four of
course maurice and thomas playing for
ascension ken and michael playing for
enterprise
that brings us back to edward jones who
again will have white in the match-up
with the top two boards playing white so
that's vishal in this case for edward
jones up against eli israe who we saw go
down quickly against john boyer uh
eli of course playing for darty
then that brings us to board two we've
got justin beckstead up against chris
cell chris who although he was crushing
his opponent thomas stack in round one
uh he was not able to actually get it
done not able to get it done uh
repeating moves one too many times
um so up and down day for chris so far
and then board three we have nathan
watson for dardy up against steven evans
for edward jones and lastly john fingers
up against alex kurford
and again hopefully we can deduce um
with with the round two information who
exactly is the no show and how that is
going to impact our standings
but that's what we've got so far and
we've got i believe another 10 minutes
or so before we get underway so i'm
gonna take another look at these round
one games do a quick little post-mortem
analysis here because this stuff was
really interesting so i want to look at
this thomas versus chris game we saw
uh
white go for this this f3 setup
uh the sameish variation of course and
go for an early queen d2 and the ideas
here are going to be kind of similar to
some ideas in you know like a sicilian
dragon or something it's a similar setup
where white's castling queen side going
for these bishop h6 ideas trying to rip
open the h file and like in some
yugoslav attack just checkmate the black
king
and so we saw you know the game sort of
following those lines here with g4 b5 h4
rookie 8 h5 b4
knight a4 so both players just launching
their pawn storm on opposite sides of
the board going for the throat going for
checkmate but then after bishop d7 and
b3 chris makes this really interesting
sacrifice knight takes g4
i'm curious what the computer thinks
about it yeah the computer thinks black
is just crushing it if you play my move
bishop takes a4 and then knight b to d7
you just want to get your knight out
push these pawns even further and white
structure is just going to be totally
shattered over here on the queen side
these a pawns not going to provide this
king much shelter
and in the meanwhile
you know this this attack might look
nice and all but you've got this not on
f6 you've got this knight on d7 ready to
come to f8 if needed they're going to
defend your king pretty well you're
going to defend your king well enough at
least so
black would have been winning with that
idea instead knight takes g4 and yeah
it's not awful for black it's not awful
for black it's it's more or less equal
in this position
but then eventually white starts to take
over here yeah queen e7
but then after bishop h6 horrible
blunder losing the knight on e2
and then this repetition believe it or
not it's it's minus eight in this
position it's minus eight here and
actually if you want to do it with the
queen on f4 you can just immediately
force the trade of queens and with that
you're just never getting checkmated you
have two you have three extra pawns and
life is just going to be very very nice
for for black but instead saw that
unfortunate repetition and thomas
claiming that draw whenever he can
so this really interesting game draw not
the result i would have predicted
let's take a look at alex's game we
didn't get to see too much of it so we
see maurice perry with e4 and we get a
french from alex with an early c5
uh and now it's a sicilian french now
it's a time enough lots of trans lots of
transpositions here
we saw alex just developing his pieces
going for uh some early pressure on this
knight over here on d2 uh white just
played bishop d2 trying to uh break this
pressure but this says this is just
gonna blunder a knight on d4
unfortunately which alex missed missed
the free knight so white had his chance
here to rectify his mistakes play knight
takes c6 but it looks like white missed
it as well and alex isn't gonna miss
that free knight a second time nate
takes d4 and from here on out i imagine
the game was smooth sailing yeah alex
immediately trades off those pieces
trade down when you're ahead on material
and
reactivates takes some extra pawns
and then this uh you know f4 f5 attack
is nothing more than a bluff for maurice
here not going to be enough to get any
real counter play
and yeah alex playing without three of
his pieces but his opponent uh those
three pieces are just sort of off the
board so uh not not as bad as you would
normally think and then yeah alex
finally does develop his remaining
pieces
and pushes his past pawn and while
rookie three ah okay so you know white
was trying to get out of this pin but
it's not going to be good enough not
going to be good enough here alex
winning that game
in style
uh also taking a look we've got this one
between thomas and stephen evans
and this one started in d4 d5 we had a
queen's gambit accepted with an early e5
i love it
so in this position for white i actually
recommend this move knight f3 you know
e4 these lines can be fun the downside
is though that's when you don't control
the e5 square black is able to just make
this pawn uh pawn push in the center and
your pawns are going to start to
collapse here so we saw d5 by white but
this is now i think just strictly better
for black you have to play knight f3
here if you want to stay in the game
instead after d5 just simply knight f6
is pressuring this guy knight c3
and then bishop c5 so not not the move i
would actually recommend
here you definitely want to go c6 really
target these pawns early or even b5 try
and secure the pawn on c4 and after b5
if you think you're going to take this
guy
you better think again because your e4
pawn is hanging so bishop c5 instead is
is fine and then we do see c6 but just
not the most accurate move order i think
black could have gotten a lot more from
this opening
instead though we got this interesting
battle uh with
okay with black pushing in the center
and then knight g5 is just an
unfortunate blunder this knight is
amazingly trapped on the g5 square just
nowhere to run
so knight takes on e4 we see a free
piece for steven and he's going to
continue with that free piece all the
way to victory it looks like yeah just
trading down again trade down when
you're up material and then he turns the
extra piece into an extra rook and the
rest is is history just pushing
and checkmate with the pawn on f6
alright cool stuff all right let me
check in let's see if no we've got four
more minutes before the second round so
we'll keep doing this little post-mortem
here
we've got justin beckstead up against
steve gilmore what happened in this game
uh bex did of course for edward jones
steve for
uh ascension and we had a queen's gambit
declined in this case uh and it's some
kind of semi-slav here
where
we've got a nice little triangle set up
okay we get c takes d5
c takes d5 going into the exchange slav
so a little bit more common here would
be e takes d5 and the reason for that is
in this position black's biggest problem
is that this bishop is just locked in
behind the e pawn so after c takes d5
and that does give black the opportunity
to sort of solve that problem allow this
bishop to come out to squares like g4
like f5 and participate in the game even
bishop e6 is is possible so e takes d5
going to be a lot more common after c
takes d5 it's tempting to go for a
totally symmetric pawn structure but
after something like e3 which is played
in the game
white is gonna have a little bit of an
edge here
the reason being we've gotten this
bishop outside our pawn chain black's
bishop is going to be a problem piece
for the foreseeable future so let's see
if that had an impact on the actual game
okay both sides are completing
development but if you just compare
these two bishops obviously you would
rather have white's piece on g5
okay queen c2
provokes g6
now 95 okay not my favorite move
actually
uh yeah i think black probably should
have taken here and gone knight g4
then
if you're not careful i think you're
just losing a pawn in fact i don't think
this pawn is defensible if you go f4
you're losing this guy on e3 so knight
or 95 would have been a good opportunity
for black instead he chooses queen c7
yeah but now that gives white time to
play this nice move f4 just solidifying
this knight here on e5 and now white can
always take back with the f pawn rip
open the f file and attack the king
so from here on out oh and yeah that's
just a free knight not so good
but white already had a very
advantageous position and then we see
bishop takes h6 and steve gilmore
decided to throw in the towel there
said it enough was enough in that
position
okay lastly but not least let's take
another quick look at this vishal game
we saw nick with the early advantage
here i think let's see if it was
actually true yeah queen b6 and things
just got awkward really really quickly
for white doing all these awkward rook
moves to try and defend your f pawn
bishop b5 queen b3
knight f6 but then vishal really turned
it around with these next couple moves
here bishop a6 but this allows queen b6
bishop b6 b4 when all of a sudden the
once super strong bishops are actually
the pieces getting harassed you know b5
is coming trapping this bishop and so
from here white wins an extra pawn and
takes control so if i'm playing with the
black pieces i think i would rather just
tuck this guy all the way back to b6
back to a6 right away it's really not
worth it to get this extra tempo on the
white queen just forces it to a better
square
and then from here you know we we can
just play uh play calm we can we can
keep everything together we can keep
this pressure down these diagonals and
white's gonna have a tough time
instead though vishal picks up this pawn
and from here we saw another interesting
choice bishop takes on d5 i think is a
very good move to just simplify things
um although you know maybe there's
there's other ideas here
and then after pawn takes
this pawn is just not going to be able
to to survive here on d5 yeah knight
takes d5 and the bishop pair is gone we
saw him trade into a winning
uh bishop end game
and yeah with
with these strong pawns over here uh
vishal was just always gonna win this
game nick also dealing with the time
deficit does end up losing here 2c8
queen equals checkmate
all right so good games for edward jones
and with that it is 6 45 p.m so i'm
gonna flip on over to our round two
and see if we can get some games going
so to reiterate we have enterprise up
against ascension here with nick nick
being the surprise in round one uh with
a very strong position against this
highest rate of player in the event of
the shawl so nick is the guy i'm going
to want to keep an eye on here see if he
can be the man to take out john boyer
of course john for enterprise nick for
ascension
uh other interesting matchups i am
curious about this chris cell person he
had a very interesting round one as well
with that uh surprise repetition but i
mean he did have a very good position
against his higher rated opponent so
we'll see if he can repeat the same feat
against justin beck said
bexted and hopefully he has learned from
his mistake in round one learned not
to repeat moves
that's my hope for justin at least and
yeah it looks like all the players are
at the boards getting ready for the
event to get underway once again
uh it looks like we've got john over
there in the corner doing some extra
some extra coaching as well before his
round starts
uh
okay
john the
good team captain
making sure all of his players know
what's going on before we get underway
okay
so
what's left what's left mike get the
tournament started everybody's waiting
what is the corporate chess league so
once again if you're just joining this
is the corporate chess league it is a uh
local to st louis uh league for
corporations in the area to compete
against each other over the chess board
and if you are in the st louis area and
are a member of a corporation you can
get involved too if you just want to
reach out to us at development at st
louis chessclub.org and that's the email
address to reach out to we would love to
have you
and we would love to see this tournament
grow
what rating is this tournament well
we're going to keep an eye on the top
couple boards here where the players are
around 1900 to 2000 strength somewhere
in that area
and
you know i'm glad they're not any
stronger than that because then i
wouldn't feel qualified to uh to tell
them that they're playing bad moves
so very nice to finally be commentating
a tournament where i'm stronger than the
players doesn't happen too often does
not happen too often normally i'm
telling like darius's weird city's
playing bad chess moves and like why
would he listen to me why would you
listen to me i don't know
okay
everybody's ready though and again i'm
curious to see who the no show was it
was either ken ma or nathan watson one
of those players did not show up to
round one and i'm hoping to find out who
it is time for round two
and games have officially started up
there in the tournament hall maybe we
can keep an eye on him uh with the
cameras but we are still waiting for
that pgn relay to come through
and wow you see them up there and
if i'm not mistaken there's a little bit
of banter going on uh in the tournament
hall as well of course this tournament
is a little bit more casual than you
know your us championships or your sing
field cups so the players you know are
allowed just just a tiny bit of a
friendly trash talk friendly banter up
there
and as we wait for the pgns to to come
out it is just really nice to to have
people playing chess in in our
tournament hall really nice to see
chess and the more social aspects of
chess coming back uh
especially in the tournament hall we've
been we have been hosting tournaments at
the st louis chess club uh throughout uh
much of 2021
but it's good to be back in our
tournament hall where we have everything
set up we have players nice and spaced
out and you know you can you can have
have some fun playing chess
with your uh
with your friends oh and just like last
game all at once we have our pgns coming
in so let's take a look nick has the
white pieces this time against john and
we see in alekhine's defense um
john was telling me about why he plays
the alkyne he thinks that this is the
opening that's going to get his
opponents out of book but i can only
hope that his opponents have not been
prepping for him although that's what it
looks like this move knight f3 not so
common against the the alakans of course
the big weakness of this opening is that
white is able to get two pawns uh far
advanced in the center uncontested to
start with knight f3 is not getting that
pawn to d4 right away
and instead we're going to see a more
conservative setup it looks like he just
plays bishop c4 brings this bishop back
and now he's going to go c3 and
eventually d4 so
just a nice solid setup here for white
not going for anything crazy
we get castles bishop e3 and after
bishop g4 we get knight out to d2
takes takes
and it looks like black might be
thinking about some kind of e4 push so
we see white play this move h3 trying to
force black to step away from this pin
and john boyer does just that with this
move bishop back to f5
so with that we have a
pretty reasonable position for both
players here i do think that there is
some discomfort here for white already i
think john's probably happy with his
position and where's that discomfort
coming from well it's all about this
queen here on d1 in order to complete
your development you want to be able to
connect these rooks together
and doing so involves moving your queen
out of the way right so a normal looking
move would be you know queen e2 since
queen c2 is under attack by the bishop
of course queen e2 here is going to be a
big mistake because bishop d3
is just going to pick up material so
white has definitely another problem
left to solve before he can claim he is
totally done with the development
totally good in the opening i think
that's why we see this move knight to g5
this move is nice that in the sense that
it attacks this f7 weak point
but more so it's really important that
we're giving this white queen a square
in the form of f3 so i expect nick's
plan here
if he gets pushed away with something
like h6 is to actually
drop this knight into the e4 square try
to come out with queen f3 and bring his
rook back to the d file to finish
development now john's not happy to just
sit back and let that happen so we see
this move knight to d5 pressuring this
bishop a little bit so now you know the
normal queen f3 black is gonna say okay
you can play queen f3 but i will take
your dark squared bishop that's the
price you have to pay for queen f3 and
that might actually just be close to
winning after queen e3 bishop h6 this
knight would have some very serious
problems on g5
so we see knight back to f3 i don't
think that this was the right right way
to respond i think that uh nick could
have actually taken over this game with
the move bishop c5 because this move uh
makes this very important defender of 7
move out of the way rook to e8 and then
queen to f3 and all of a sudden the
things are lining up around black's king
here you can come back with bishop e6
but i'm just going to take this guy
you have to take with the pawn to defend
your knight then after knight to e4 just
look at the the harmony with all of
white's pieces all angling towards the
same side of the board the knight
defending the bishop looking at those
weak points in the black camp i would be
very very happy with white here
now that being said we see knight gf3
instead and yeah jon's just going to
take off this dark squared bishop and
use that as a as a way to gain an
advantage yeah now the dart now that the
dark squared bishop is gone jon goes
queen b6 he's aiming for those newly
weakened dark squares
uh nick in the meantime plays knight to
c4 he's fighting back for those squares
as well and he really just needs a
square for this queen this queen is just
so uncomfortable on this open file it
needs to get off of it but you know e2
is not the most comfortable square
either again
bishop d3 is no longer immediately
playable but it is going to be uh you
know a source of some discomfort for
some time to come here
so that's the question for nick what do
you do with this queen where does it go
where is its home
and i actually think i want to stick
with this game a little bit because this
is a very interesting position here you
know white definitely had some early
opportunities to to take the lead but uh
now under some pressure he has problems
to solve we'll see if nick is is up to
the task
is he up to the task
if i'm white here i think my move is
gonna have to be this move queen to e2
and how am i gonna meet this move rook a
to d8 well i'm actually thinking i am
just going to go with e4
and my point now is that yes you've
gotten rid of my dark squared bishop yes
these squares are going to be weak but
i'm hoping it doesn't matter i'm hoping
i'm about to plant a knight onto the d5
square and i am just going to fight you
on the light squares that's where my
battle will take place i might even put
my knight on g5 for a second time you
know i know i'm moving back and forth a
little bit but that's what i want oh
instead queen to d6 and this one feels a
little bit wrong in my opinion you know
it's a nice advancing move it feels good
to put your pieces into the enemy camp
like this
uh but the fact of the matter is black
now has the bishop pair and so if things
continue to get traded we continue to
inch towards an end game you know white
has more weaknesses black has the better
minor pieces and the end games are going
to favor black in this position so
that's why i like this move queen e2
just a little bit more
okay with that in mind though queen d6
rook a to c8
and what's going on here for white we
get knight out to g5
okay so uh white though is still putting
on the pressure here uh and he's not
following a plan that's too dissimilar
to what i was uh
what i was advising there he is going
after black on the light squares knight
g5 he's targeting f7 if black were to be
so bold as to capture on d6 be a big
mistake look at all these pieces just
lining up together uh on f7 no way is
blank going to be able to hold all of
those weaknesses together so queen takes
d6 is is no good here but that begs the
question if you don't take on d6 what do
you do
h6 is also going to be too bold i think
uh nick would take on on f7 in a
heartbeat
and go for queen takes on c7 and go for
stuff like knight to d6 check knight
takes on e5 check these kinds of
sacrifices i think are very very
tempting
maybe even queen takes first and then
take here and the idea is
now after knight d6
no comfortable way to to escape this pin
if you go here you know i take
if you take back i can take and play e4
not so good not so good for john so real
serious problems here in the position uh
for john boyer let me just refresh
things a little bit oh age six and nick
again was just not up to the challenge
couldn't come up with the moves let me
let me just check here i think uh yeah
something like e4 is quite strong i
think queen c7 rick c7 knight f7 yet
this is just close to winning for white
black's best move here
king age seven
not so happy not so happy but nick you
know was not in a position to call john
boyer's bluff he just didn't believe in
it and because of that uh we see that
john
is
escaping with his life here and escaping
with his life is
is actually pretty nice it's pretty nice
here with black again
at some point the bishop's pair will
tell the tale as a as they say the
bishop's pair will will tell the tale is
that a real saying i don't know but let
us continue on we have
um already a result between michael
prather and maurice perry let's see what
happened here uh we got a four knights
defense we saw an exchange on c6 in an
early d4
so a pretty typical e4 e5 game so far
and more exchanges occurred michael just
taking pieces off whenever possible and
then just missing a hanging piece yeah
that's tough that's tough
uh one thing that i think might be going
on just a little bit here today is a
little over the board blindness these
guys they're used now they're used to
playing
online chess everybody is everybody is
used to online chess and
when you get so used to playing on a
virtual board like that you can start to
lose some of that board vision that
you've trained up for over the board
chess the pieces just look different
they feel different and we're going to
see more blunders than normal tonight
that being said looks like that extra
piece was enough for maurice to to win
the game without too many
uh too much controversy and oh wow this
is
quite nasty the bishops and the rook
controlling almost every square in the
back rank then michael just missing
rookie one with checkmate very strong
very strong stuff we have another result
as well
uh vishal bardwash has already won
against eli asrati
uh looks like we had a dutch here and
vishal playing one of the main normal
lines
and
kind of coincidentally going for a very
similar plan to what we saw last game
going for e4 now i am more familiar with
this plan in this position i think it's
a lot more common here for white to play
for this early e4 break
and this is just another blunder this is
another blunder by by eli so over the
board blindness it's claiming quite a
few victims tonight and so vishal going
up tons and tons of pieces early on
and that's going to be enough to win the
game get rick a7
and check and oh that's a nasty
checkmate knight d7
and the queen
covers it all
nasty stuff nasty nasty stuff so
two results already in the books
and by the way michael prather that's
enterprises player right there so
ascension
is the team that grabs the lead early on
from enterprise of course enterprise and
edward jones the only two champions in
corporate chess league history so
anytime you see them struggling with a
team it's it's big news so maybe
ascension is the team to do it
and amazingly
the two players that
uh had their game end in forfeit due to
a no-show they're both here now they're
both playing chess so very interesting
stuff
and it's more bad news for enterprise uh
i'm no mathematician but i'm counting
the number of pieces on this chessboard
black has more queens so having more
queens seems pretty good
and black is also thomas schaffbuk also
playing for ascension so if black is
able to convert this game to a full
points
um that's gonna put ascension at a two
zip lead meaning enterprise could no
longer win the match
and in fact the game is going along the
lines i expected bishop takes d5 seems
like a nice tactic you unleash the rooks
onto the rook on f8 but then there's no
follow-up black still has way more
pieces and after rook f7 thomas does
find queen takes f7 sacrificing the
queen for two rooks
and now the rest is is history here no
way is ken going to survive this one
barring any stalemate tricks which
you can never completely count out
so that's that would be two zip for
ascension enterprise cannot win in this
match against ascension any longer and
this is over and this game is over we
have resignation from ken
uh and this was my concern with the
enterprise lineup yes they have super
strong john boyer on board one one of
the strongest players in the events
but
those lower boards that's where they
were lacking just a little bit lacking
an experience lacking in raiding and it
came back to bite them a little bit with
this match against ascension
let's check in on steve gilmore against
thomas stack so thomas stack for
enterprise this is now a must-win game
if they are to hold a draw in the match
against ascension but it does seem like
thomas is doing very very well here with
an extra knight so thomas and john
they've got to get it done now they've
got to get it done
and by the way
john's position looking a little shaky
uh white did end up uh once again
fighting for those light squares that's
really what you have to do when you give
up one of your bishops you fight for
that color complex um
uh of the other color you know you give
up your dark square bishop you got to be
fighting for the light squares and
nick is is succeeding in that in
controlling the d5 square that being
said i i do have to prefer black here i
think this bishop on g7 just has some
latent power that we're we're not really
seeing yet for example c move like f5
come on the board and all of a sudden
this bishop starts to uh to get a little
bit more active starts to pressure these
guys back here on b2 and c3
and white might get into a little bit of
trouble so
do you think we have good chances for
john here but he needs to needs to needs
to win in order to tie this match and
yeah we do see f5 john of course is
going to know about that one
okay so tense situation in the
enterprise ascension matchup but let's
check out
how edward jones is doing against darny
we have justin beckstedt on board two up
against chris cell chris with a strong
showing in round one but not strong
enough to take home a full point so
what's going on here
well neither player is down any pieces
yet so it must be a close game
also very close on the clock i do think
justin is the rating favorite by some
margin
but with the time situation you know
it's it's anybody's game here it's it's
truly anybody's game we see a trade of
bishop for knight on b5 and if i'm chris
you know i i got to keep it moving here
i got to keep it moving just a little
bit we actually see
chris taking a free pawn on e4
going up in material now so chris again
with a very strong showing
but yeah both players you just you got
to keep that pace up you got to keep
that pace up once the time ticks down to
under two minutes it's not like you have
two minutes on an online chessboard
where you can pre-move for days you know
this is two minutes on a physical
chessboard every time you make a move
you pick up a piece you put it down and
you hit a clock that takes some time
that takes some very serious time
and these players are quite close to
flagging
quite close to flagging
and that being said it looks like chris
might actually get it done here chris
trying to be a hero for the doherty team
trying to score those points against the
very formidable edward jones
yeah chris maintaining that 30 second
time edge is it's critical it's
absolutely critical
and yeah you see these players you know
they do have some over the board
experience you can tell by the way they
move the pieces you know so smooth and
yet still uh still quite quick
quite quick the way they uh they are
maneuvering
so
uh justin gaining a little bit of ground
on the clock i feel like chris might be
falling for a classic trap here when you
have a good position
you tend to want to spend a little time
on it you know you want to think you
want to appreciate it you don't want to
mess it up by playing some bad move
quickly but sometimes spending time is
the worst thing you can do in a position
like this you just need to keep good
natural moves flowing
uh so that you don't lose on time oh and
rookie eight oh chris no that's gonna be
blundering a full rook
and i wonder if that was enough to uh to
get resignation from chris i hope not
the time situation it's still anybody's
game and yeah no he he did continue on
he did continue on
um but yeah with that i have to think
that justin is going to be the heavy
favorite here
let's check back in as we're entering
time pressure
for nick versus john okay john ended up
winning a bishop that's going to be good
enough for a victory there no matter
what the time situation and here king
takes e5 powerful move but i think
actually what happened here is steve
gilmore resigned so
john and thomas getting it done when
they absolutely needed to
and tying their match against ascension
and they're lucky to get that tie with
the two lower boards just showing an
absolutely crushing performance
okay let's check back in now on these
other games
this game is still well underway chris
though
faltering in time pressure and in fact
just losing a queen now
very sad very sad for chris okay nathan
watson in the meantime is losing against
uh stephen evans here
three extra pieces is pretty good and on
the the lower board here we have jon
fingers against alex crawford
and my clock is showing
zero seconds for john fingers i wonder
if this is actually the case um i
suspect that that john did actually flag
here so let's keep an eye on this justin
becksted chris cell game as things
continue to heat up you see the players
moving at lightning speed oh and they
have now uh completed their game i
believe chris lost
uh either on time or or on the board
uh so with that i think edward jones
might be keeping their their perfect
record i think they are now 8 and 0 on
the evening very
very impressive stuff by by edward jones
so far
very impressive stuff
okay in the meanwhile enterprise i do
think just only managed to draw their
match against ascension and that's gonna
take us to the close of round two we saw
some games going rather long there some
some very impressive matchups and very
impressive games from these players
so where does that leave us well i think
we're probably going to be a little bit
behind schedule now we were slated to
start i think it's 7 10
but maybe now uh we are actually
starting at 7 15 rather than 7 10. so
we've got just about five more minutes
before the final round of the action
gets underway
so let's take a look at some of these
crazy games this was absolutely wild how
did john boyer win a piece here i was
just starting to like white's position
again oh no don't tell me yeah
he did uh he did fail at this f5 moment
f5 puts a ton of pressure onto white's
position it's challenging
um what we call the strong point in
white's position white's entire position
revolves around this e4 pawn being here
you take this pawn away black is pushing
e4 ripping open this bishop and just
with with a huge advantage so john plays
knight d6 plays f5 puts on the pressure
onto this point for white and white just
wasn't able to maintain this pawn here
now you know you don't have to hang a
piece just yet you can play something
like knight to b4
allow the take here and try and blockade
this pawn
and maybe you stay in the game for
another little bit but of course a very
difficult position now for white instead
white just tuck on f5 which of course is
losing to king takes d5 with an extra
piece now for john
f6 is going to provide
white a little bit of counter play but
not nearly enough
just trades some pieces off
and collects this f6 pawn with the rook
and after that an extra bishop is an
extra bishop and the extra bishop turns
into an extra queen and the extra queen
turns into a victory for john boyer very
exciting finish there
let's see it looks like chris did just
resign after queenie one rookie one
going down that extra queen just too
demoralizing for chris to continue
uh meanwhile what happened in this
thomas stack game how did he win all
these pieces um
we saw him be up the piece very early on
so let's see what happened here we saw a
break in the center knight e5 ooh and
knight d4 and i guess things got a
little bit tricky with this pin uh for
white saw bish knight takes bishop
knight takes takes takes
bishop takes g6 oh come on uh unforced
heirs from steve gilmore here uh you
know you thought he saw a nice little
tactic but it's it's just not gonna work
out for him and in fact i'm not really
sure what he was hoping for so
it looks like he thought he was getting
the classic tactic you move the bishop
with checker with a big threat you
challenge the enemy queen and black
can't deal with both problems at once
now there's a number of reasons why it
doesn't work here number one the queen
is defended number two this move isn't
check
so
no way this tactic was ever working
black just takes the free bishop and is
up a full clean piece here
again
some of that over-the-board blindness i
think is is taking its toll on these
players and a quick resignation then
from steve to follow that
continuing on down the line uh how did
thomas win this extra queen here
we have fairly normal opening position
d5 looks like it's actually winning a
piece for whites we saw bishop a4 very
good you want to drop the bishop back
keep this pin alive
and then yeah white gus just goes up a
clean piece
but something goes horribly wrong here
okay bishop f4 walks into this g5 tactic
so no longer an extra piece
then it looks like these bishops
just became very very very strong for
for black
and eventually ah so this is the tactic
that steve thought he was playing in the
other game rook lined up with the queen
bishop moves with check to the enemy
king you can't deal with both threats
and you do end up winning winning the
queen
uh and then yeah the rest is is history
here the rest is history
uh thomas getting it done with the extra
queen
okay last but not least let's check out
what happened in these other two games
we saw nathan watson with the white
pieces getting an early fork
bishop g4 though bishop g5
f6 does keep two pieces under under
threat
so knight e4 yes steven up to an early
lead then with the extra piece
and then some more bad tactics it looks
like by whites you know knight h7 but
falling for this inner meso here queen
e7 check saving the queen picking up a
second extra piece
and then a third extra piece after
castles
and three extra pieces is a lot of extra
pieces it's a lot of extra pieces i'm
not gonna lie three is a lot
so steven winning that game and then
last but not least let's check in on
this game it looks like this game was
maybe surprisingly competitive with a
difficult end game here for white to be
sure but some some holding chances and a
practical game
but unfortunately for john i think he
did just flag in this position but what
what happened here
looks like alex was was under some
pressure out of the opening a strong
knight on d6 active rook on c6
but what happens here
b5 bishop back to c8
okay interesting stuff uh and then just
knight takes on c8 yeah i'm not so sure
about this idea okay and i'm definitely
not so sure about rook takes c8 uh your
advantage here with white is your
activity you want to keep your active
pieces around try and invade with
something like rick to c7
rook to c8 in particular strikes me as
uh not the best move because then black
is the one who gets active and you're
not going to be able to hold on to
things here
and yeah we see that black constructs
the bathtub structure with these pawns
the king sitting pretty in the bathroom
i have to flip the board for it to make
sense see it's a bathtub black king
taking a bath relaxing chilling and
that's enough for jon fingers to lose
the game so impressive impressive stuff
so far from edward jones off to an eight
and zero start scoring at 56 points so
far if my math is correct and they're
going for the max they're going for 72
out of 72 points
and it looks like all the players are
congregating looking around trying to
find their boards getting ready for this
final round of play round three coming
soon
in the meantime let me take a quick look
over here see how we're doing in the
online portion of this event
and i have no idea i have absolutely no
idea i have no results so far for the
online standings
but that's okay i'm sure they're playing
i'm sure they're playing their games
having a blast
but i did want to reiterate that both
edward jones and enterprise are playing
in the online portion of this hybrid
event as well that's going to give them
some really nice opportunities to score
some extra points and pull ahead from
the rest of the field
meanwhile worldwide technology the only
team in the top four to not be here for
the in person portion of the corporate
chess league so they are competing
online they are trying to hold their
spot in the number two position here
trying to make sure they qualify for the
final four playoffs in november
uh once again just a brief reminder of
the format this is week number four of
the corporate chess league and there is
just one more week of the regular season
coming up uh in november
and that's the last chance for these
teams to score points for the grand prix
so they are competing to be in the top
four when the grand prix ends at the
next corporate chess league event
and if they do qualify in the final four
we will see them all here back in the st
louis chess club in person for the
corporate chess league finals
competing to get their name on that
board
okay with all that let's pull up round
number three take a look at our pairings
it's the round we've all been waiting
for it's the matchup we've all been
waiting for who are we kidding it's
edward jones vs enterprise these two
teams are now long time rivals in the
corporate chess league with edward jones
always looking to be dominant but
enterprise being the only team able to
rip away the championship from their
clutches back in 2020 so we'll see if
enterprise can do it again and we'll see
if this is foreshadowing a little bit
what we can expect come november in the
final four i there's really no doubt in
my mind
especially with this performance tonight
enterprise and edward jones we're gonna
be seeing them in the final four and
we're gonna be seeing them square off uh
hopefully in the championship finals uh
although they might they might be facing
off a little bit earlier that being said
you definitely can't count out worldwide
technology or ascension in the finals i
mean we just saw ascension tie their
match against enterprise and quite
nearly win it quite nearly win it
so any team has has a chance to uh to
take home that trophy
um while we wait though let's see what
we actually have as far as our
individual board matchups go so board
one that's going to be john boyer whose
games we've been following a little bit
more closely up against vishal bardwash
so the top two rated players in the
tournaments uh so that'll be definitely
a game to look out for john again is
gonna have to to win on board one for
his team because the matchups on the
lower boards they're not looking pretty
we have thomas stack on board two
against justin beckstead
and again all of these edward jones
players are undefeated so far tonight
they they have all won all of their
games
uh so thomas is looking at more than a
400 400-point rating deficit up against
justin
meanwhile on board three stephen evans
also with about a 400 point lead over
his opponent ken ma and then lastly we
have alex up against michael prather
with a
700 point
rating advantage so alex the the
definite favorite there and we have
games and oh my god we both have games
and a pgn file okay so let's take a look
here at what's going on we're definitely
going to spend quite a bit of time on
board number one here this is the
match-up of the tournament and what do
we have we have an italian so far and we
have mike comer's recommendation long
time fans of mike in the st louis chess
club channel will know that mike says
you are a fool if you allow the fried
liver liver attack you are a fool
so mike says
stop that in its tracks play h6 so
vishal maybe got some last second advice
from mike before this round got underway
of course though h6 does come with some
downsides namely it does nothing to
impact the center of the board that's
why john breaks with d4 we get ed4
knight d4 queen e7 now and we are in
novelty territory this has never been
played uh according to the lead chess
database
okay knight to c3 d6 and now kingside
castles
so what on earth is going on here well
i have to say that it looks like the
shawl might be under some pressure early
on it is a very big concession to play
this move h6 so early on
because you know you're just you're not
impacting the center that's why white is
enjoying this comfortable space
advantage this pawn much further
advanced than black's d-pawn this pawn
is just you know making life
uncomfortable for black it's making it
so this bishop can't comfortably develop
and it's you know introducing all sorts
of threats into the position like knight
d5 attacking all kinds of squares it's
helping this bishop uh attack the king's
side of the board with with bishop f7
threats
uh and yeah this knight on d4 also
enjoying its central outpost in the
meantime we see some very cagey play by
vishal here knight e5 gains a tempo on
this bishop and then bishop d7 and if i
didn't know any better i would say black
is looking to castle on the queen's side
of the board
uh and that's going to make for a very
interesting game although i'm i'm still
not quite convinced in in black's
opening play here i think white should
have a a very nice advantage
uh it's enough to give john some pause
though he's he's worried about this
queenside castles he's worried about you
know the the attack on the king's side
that's going to ensue stuff like g5 g4
h5 h4 it's it's going to be very
interesting very interesting to see
and yeah hello once again to the youtube
chat
obvi says he expects a botez gambit from
black you you underestimate vishal uh
the show
of the show is over now did you shook
him boyer vashall is over they just
shook hands what is this what is going
on i need to see this i need to see this
for myself
um let's see if we can get that view of
the players yeah they're they're
chatting with each other
but what's going on they they shook
hands they stopped the clock
and then he played queen d8
and then he played h3
what is happening did they agree to a
quick draw
what is happening
what is happening here all right
oh you know what i think happened
here let me
hold hold on let me place the moves on
my board here
no they didn't forget to stop to start
the clock that's that was my concern i
thought maybe they forgot to start the
clock
but uh
yeah knight d5 and then the timestamps
go away they must have stopped the clock
oh man who knows what is what is going
on here
did they agree to withdraw there's no
way they're still playing moves
they're still like playing chess over
here
comer's at the board advising yeah the
the clock is stopped
the clock is officially stopped they
seem to be chatting oh i love this we're
like investigating live
the game's definitely over okay game's
definitely over and it is officially a
draw i have the result here
so
i i'm flabbergasted a quick draw on the
corporate chess league and this is a
first
this is an absolute first john boyer and
vishal agreeing to a quick draw and that
shatters edward jones's dreams of going
the perfect uh 12-0 although i'm sure
they would be happy with a win here
nonetheless well with that let's take a
look at board two board two still going
no more quick draws uh over here
and what a position we do have we have
thomas with the white pieces for
enterprise up against justin beckstead
with black
and after b5 i would be getting a little
bit nervous here
with the black pieces uh i think we've
seen thomas
with a very similar position
with this f3 set up against the king's
indian defense against
i believe it was chris sell
in round one but
thomas here is going for some trades on
g7 some invasions with something like
queen
to h6 and then hoping for the pressure
down the h file to be enough to win the
game
that being said i'm not seeing the
checkmate here for white and so black is
happy to just continue with b5 continue
pressuring over here on the queen side
um in the meantime we do see takes and
takes on the board so the players are
following my line we see f takes g6 here
and if you're a little bit newer at
chess you might be surprised to see f
tanks you know you're told capture
towards the center but of course in this
case the h pawn provides some much
needed shelter for the black king so we
take with the f pawn
that way in this position the h pawn
keeps these white major pieces at bay
and the absence of the f-pawn actually
allows some nice defensive moves here
for black as well you're able to defend
along this seventh rank and sort of uh
keep this attack
from checkmating your king so
immediately and this is the current
position now on the board
so interesting stuff thomas going for
the throat right away
but i think the problem is going to run
into is you know it's sort of a question
of what next you know you took off that
dark squared bishop you got your queen
into h6 you got everything you wanted
but now what black isn't checkmated the
game isn't over what do you do
and that's why i think that this
especially this g5 move that was just
played was a little bit rushed you know
g5 looks great you're getting rid of
this knight that defends the checkmate
but not h5 is more than adequate to stop
your attack from breaking through
and so we see okay we see thomas just
breaking now with rook takes on h5 but
this isn't nearly enough you know you're
attacking with one piece
uh so if i had the white pieces here i
would have definitely recommended you
know playing something like like knight
h3 to start with or even in this
position
knight h3 you need to bring in more and
more attackers for your you know king
side attack to be to be successful
you can't just attack with two pieces
and you definitely can't just attack
with one piece that's not going to be
enough for checkmate
so now i do believe uh justin is about
to take over the game play something
like queen g6 even just totally solidify
things and in the meantime don't forget
plaque is attacking himself over here on
the the queen side
the good news for black especially
though is that
he's officially up material white has
sacrificed a rook on h5 and so any
trades only bring the game closer to a
very very good ending for black with the
extra material so justin in firm control
uh over over this game
ts says it's been 10 years since you
last played chess uh time to dust off
the chessboard absolutely that's what
we're doing here with a lot of these
players as well i think this is uh
almost everyone in the event's first
tournament back to over-the-board chess
in a long long time so really exciting
stuff glad we can have them here
playing chess once again
okay so justin now continues with b
takes on c4 trying to open up this b
file
and i fully expect him now to to take
complete control over this game yeah
queen g6 that move that i mentioned also
coming on the board uh offering up this
queen trade and getting closer and
closer
to that winning position
okay let's continue down the board then
we have uh stephen evans uh with the
white pieces for edward jones up against
ken ma
and it looks like another difficult
position for ken you see this bishop on
before is a incr an incredibly annoying
piece uh all it's doing is keeping this
black king in the center uh what's the
big deal about that well as long as this
black king's in the center this black
rook is not able to enter the game also
i just counted the pieces white has more
bishops and more rooks so looks good for
steven uh last but not least let's take
a look see how alex kurford is doing
again i think he out rates his opponent
by 700 rating points so he should be
doing well should be doing well it looks
like uh michael's putting up a fair bit
of resistance though you know
i'm not seeing any extra pieces for
white so that's definitely something
the position though does seem like it is
quite nice for alex and i say that
because the black king is miles away uh
weaker than this than this white king
you know you see no shelter in front of
this king the hg pawns provide some very
nice shelter for for the white king
so black definitely in trouble here
although i do want to stick with this
game because this looks like the the
closest match up here in the edward
jones uh enterprise
battle okay 95 that's a really nice move
for alex he's threatening both a fork on
f7 and to just take this g6 pawn off the
board
uh and you know taking off the g6 pawn
that's a luxury that white can afford
because he does have the shelter around
his king you know you might think twice
as black about removing the a4 pawn from
the board but here yeah uh if i'm alex
i'm probably just taking this guy you
know why not a pawn is a pawn
he does have other options though for
example rook a to c1 looks quite
tempting
coming in with knight c6 and more
attacking ideas queen a6 also a very
tempting move uh there's there's a lot
of ways here for white to
take a serious lead
okay knight g6 bishop d6 i like this
move by michael uh bishop d6 brings the
bishop into the game and does put at
least a little bit of pressure onto alex
skirford's position
at least a little bit of pressure here
uh and so alex now finding himself maybe
without a home for this night you might
want to come back to e5 but i don't know
if you're thrilled about allowing takes
takes in this queen uh trying to invade
over here i don't know if you're
absolutely thrilled about that
um so alex probably gonna take a second
here make sure he knows what's going on
um i should also mention some funny
lines here at 95 bishop e5 you might be
considering queen takes h5 but i think
there's the surprising tactic bishop
takes d4 there if you take the queen
take e3 with check and then take back
not the first time we've seen these
weird pin discovered attack type ideas
between the queens
so bishop d6 here and yeah it's it's on
alex now to come up with something it's
on alex
what to do where to put the pieces
uh and because of this move i do think
that maybe queen a6 was was a simpler
way of going about things you just you
plop this queen right in front of that
black king make him know that he is not
safe on this chessboard and uh
the the rest of the moves sort of play
themselves bring the rook in you bring
the knight in and you checkmate the
black king
oh and hello to patrick in the chat a
long time viewer patrick daly
alex is pretty crushing why not a king
attack yeah i agree
okay what wouldn't have taken g6
principle it keeps your king safer yeah
and that seems to be what's what's going
on here for for alex i i i'm coming
around to the idea that we really should
have just attacked the black king
instead of going pawn hunting here
that being said you know you're you're
definitely still winning this position
with uh with white so alex played this
slightly weird move rook a to d1
the point though was pretty logical he
wanted to play this move knight e5 but
he wanted to make sure that the black
queen wasn't going to invade into his
camp uh whenever he did play this move
so just preparing this move knight e5
was the idea now after queen to b3 uh
you're a little bit spoiled for choice
here you can take the knight but then
queen takes b2 actually threatens
checkmate so i think much simpler is
just give this check just take this rook
leave this queen back here where it
defends your king
and uh only after you do all that do you
think about taking a knight
okay queen b5 instead this is
not my favorite move
not my favorite move you know now queen
e3 check is threatened queen takes b2 is
threatened and honestly you've got to
start thinking about rook takes g2 ideas
like you have to start thinking about
those ideas as well
okay king c8 also not my favorite move i
would have rather come to the the a8
square where i am not on this open file
and feel a little bit safer but king c8
and bishop c7 is michael prather's
choice
uh but if these last few moves have
taught me anything you know the game
could go either way although
this is checkmate and two this is
checkmate and two i think alex probably
is going to be able to find that one
you know check one king b8 only move
check two that's checkmate and the
game's over so
king c8 turns out to be turns out to be
the fatal mistake for for michael
turns out to be the fatal mistake and
are we going to see it on the board
are we going to see it on the board
and it's over alex gets it done with
this knight c6 checkmate
okay with that i believe edward jones
has officially won the match against uh
enterprise the only game left in the air
for this match is this justin beck said
thomas stack game and boy oh boy what an
absolute
mess they have made of this chessboard
my god i know you know some people say
that like you know chess is an art form
but if chess is an art form this is like
you know th this is the the proverbial
you know urinal in the art museum that
they've done here oh my god look at this
like
you know just
organization of pieces i've never seen
this many pieces like stacked up in you
know alternating colors this is really
something here
this is it's a work of something it's a
work of something to be sure
um okay that being said maybe i've been
a little bit harsh uh i do think black
is is still just winning he's got this f
file under control he's still got the
extra exchange it looks like still just
in exchange now after bishop takes e2
he's going to invade and black might
actually be getting uh getting
checkmated
black might be getting checkmated here
oh and looking at the board uh oh no
they are at the board it looks like that
was a different game we were taking a
glimpse at okay so bishop takes e2 i
think justin beckstead has this well
under control let's pop in then on the
other game going on uh between the other
match going on between darty and
ascension looks like nick finally gets
this chance to shine he put up a very
impressive amount of resistance on board
one he had a tough night lined up
between playing john boyer and vishal uh
both of the strongest players in the
event but he held a zone he didn't score
any points against them though and now
he finally gets his time to shine
playing eli asrati who also had a tough
night on board one of course and oh my
god oh no tell me this didn't actually
happen tell me this didn't actually
happen c5 queen c7 95
is it true
is it true
say it isn't so
say it isn't so oh my goodness okay
well the free queen was missed um so not
the cleanest game but by nick then
uh
yeah it looks like some some other
tactics might be going on here
but at the end of the day he wins the
pawn on c5 he finds
a nice way to untangle his pieces and
then
trades down into a winning end game it
looks like and then
checkmate is hung by by eli that's good
enough for a win for nick okay in the
meantime we've got chris for doherty who
again has also been putting up some very
impressive games uh on board two did get
that half point against thomas stack for
enterprise
and what's going on here well he has
fewer rooks that's what's going on here
so
looking good for ascension on the top
two boards looks like two points for
them uh barring any mishaps
and then on board three again it does
look good for ascension although white
has just blundered a piece so in this
position white is up a piece and a rook
in this position white is only going to
be up a piece but or only going to be up
a rook rather excuse me
i think maybe the bishops moving
backwards was missed by uh by thomas
um
so tough tough there but an extra rook
should still be good enough and lastly
we've got maurice against jon fingers
and either we've got a relay air or
another quick draw because i'm only on
move three in this position looks like
this game is is probably over by now but
we'll have to wait to find out what
exactly happened
on this board
okay checking back in what's the most
competitive game still going um
i guess you could argue it's this one
where justin bexted is now up an extra
piece
uh and just okay very cleanly winning
now h2 rook g1 and black gets a queen
so that one's not super competitive this
one uh
black does have more rooks and i
wouldn't be surprised if this is
actually a resignation here by chris
that game is over uh yeah so chris
probably resigned in that position
and this one
white has more rooks so i guess we're
sticking here we'll see what happens
here
um
worst case thomas only needs a half
point to secure the match victory here
for uh ascension
and of course edward jones has
officially secured match victory against
enterprise and likely finishing just a
half point away from a completely
perfect record on the night so vishal
not wanting to test his medal against
john boyer tonight agreed to a quick
draw
and that is going to leave edward jones
assuming justin doesn't mess this up
with 71 and a half out of 72 points
and yeah justin officially wins uh
against thomas so 71 and a half out of
72 on the night for edward jones and
that's not even counting their
performance in the virtual section
okay and
actually it looks like all the games
might have actually concluded so
a little bit of a mystery here i'm
assuming that ascension did end up
winning that match against dhardi uh
they have two confirmed points and then
two mysterious positions it looks like
thomas resigned being or no thomas won
nathan resigned being down uh
well actually potentially thomas flagged
in this position no surely not okay i
think thomas probably won against nathan
and that gives ascension that that match
victory there
so the big winners of the night
definitely edward jones is it enough for
them to surpass uh their uh
their competitors worldwide technology
and enterprise well it remains to be
seen they definitely picked up some
ground though 71.5 out of 72 points and
that's
that's a performance i don't think
anyone could have anticipated so very
strong stuff from edward jones tonight
ascension getting that tied match
against enterprise they have to be happy
with that result enterprise fueling such
a strong team every week and enterprise
not doing so bad themselves
although if any team's disappointed
tonight i'm willing to bet it's it's
enterprise and potentially doherty who
also had a very tough night
um so very very strong stuff tonight at
the corporate chess league we saw some
blunders as we always do some of that
over the board blindness setting in on
the players and yeah you now see the fun
part of corporate chess league the
tournament's over it's time to just hang
out and talk about your chess games talk
about your night see how it's going up
there in the tournament hall
okay
with all of that i think it's just about
time we wrap up our show here so thank
you all so much for joining us for uh
our first ever hybrid events corporate
chess league i had a great time covering
all these games hopefully you had a good
time seeing them as well and hopefully
you catch us here in november for that
final week of the grand prix which will
be online and then
the moment we've all been waiting for
all season long the final four the
playoffs the real action
it's going to be a blast so as always my
name is caleb denby thank you so much
for watching and i will see you next
time
you